tell me how I feel
[Music]
do tell me how to feel like we did when
we
were you would take the reaload yeah we
were on the
Run and I remember night we would sing
till we saw the
sun oh just tell me how feel like we de
we we
young
so yeah you were danc since see
s all my friends are they singing
alone
we got down we got high
overing
light so let's run free and me young
like we did when we were young flower
when we drive R through the
town oh we roll the windows down so the
cows won't come
around Tak me the time things are fine
it's so broken
now yeah but always keeping mind things
are fine and we'll figure it
out yeah you Dan since see
song and so my friends are
singing We got down we got high
moment so
right so let's run free and
car like away you were
young like did we were
[Music]
young
[Applause]
[Music]
show me how to feel like we did when we
were
young
oh tell me I feel like we de with we
were young young young so you
oh yeah you Dan toing
song so my friends to leave s Alone s
alone we got down we we got high we got
the moment s so
right so that's one dream car me on like
could
I
so
[Music]
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that
video I think this is actually the first
sponsored flow video I've ever shot on
my channel that was not shot in the DC
area no this was actually shot in
Columbus Ohio when I was visiting my
girlfriend dizzy for Valentine's Day so
I hope you all enjoyed a slight change
up in uh theme and venue um real quick I
just want to give a quick uh shout out
to flow toys for sponsoring this video
and giving me a reason to get out and
flow wherever I happen to be in my
travels if you'd like to grab a set of
those flow Mojo that I was using in this
video you can do so by using the promo
code Drex Factor 2202 24 at checkout
over flowtoys.com once again that is
drexfactor
22024 thanks so much again to flow toys
for sponsoring this video and speaking
of thank yous uh big thank yous go out
to the Friends of the channel that is
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Tera light toys spinballs and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thank you to the non- business friend of
the channel That is Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission finally
uh this video would not be possible
without the amazing support of all those
awesome people that helped to contribute
to this channel over on patreon in
particular I would like to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right here um if you like to see
more of the work that I create here
whether it be these flow videos
tutorials video essays Etc you can do
that uh and make sure that more of them
are coming to the general public by
heading on over and signing up at
patreon.com drexfactor po there are also
some awesome rewards there so do check
it out please and thank you um thank you
again for watching this video if you'd
like to see more of my flow videos I'll
include a link to a playlist of those
down in the description as well as up on
screen if you are watching on YouTube uh
go ahead and get out and Flo day and I
will see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace